[Applaudissements]
connaissez-vous l'histoire des aveugles
qui découvrent un éléphant pour la
première fois
ils doivent se le décrire alors le
premier touche les flancs c'est comme un
mur le deuxième touche les pattes c'est
plutôt comme un tronc d'arbre le
troisième touche la trompe dit non non
ça s'enroule comme un serpent
aucun n'a décrit l'éléphant et pourtant
chacun a une part de vérité
pour avoir l'éléphant complet il faut
qu'il discute entre eux
et bien aujourd'hui dans les sciences
fondamentales on a le même problème
nous avons des formations qui
fonctionnent en silo avec les
informaticiens les physiciens les
mathématiciens les biologistes et chacun
dans sa discipline va développer une
connaissance de pointe une part de
vérité mais quand il est question de
pluridisciplinarité de discuter avec les
champs disciplinaires différents de soi
parfois c'est plus compliqué
pourtant on sent bien que avoir un
regard différent sur un problème c'est
une approche intéressante c'est
enrichissant
alors qu'est-ce qui fait que parfois la
communication est difficile entre les
domaines
c'est la question que je me pose au
quotidien
car au sein des sciences j'ai une
position très particulière
je fais des traitements du signal
c'est une petite discipline qui n'est
pas très connue entre la physique et
l'informatique et pourtant on la
retrouve partout
aussi bien en intelligence artificielle
que dans les télécommunications ou même
en sciences humaines quand on cherche à
rendre accessible une peinture une œuvre
d'art à des personnes malvoyantes
c'est la science qui s'intéresse à
l'information à la communication à
comment est-ce qu'on transmet un message
elle fait l'interface entre différentes
disciplines
et c'est une boîte à outils au service
de la pluridisciplinarité
si bien qu'au quotidien je dois être
capable de discuter avec des personnes
de champ disciplinaire très différents
et je me suis rendu compte que nous
avions un problème
tous
nous avons un problème au niveau du
langage
les mots qu'on utilise sont comme des
éléphants
c'est l'exemple par exemple du jargon
quand on a différents experts qui
discutent on a l'impression de parler de
la même chose les flancs de l'éléphant
les pattes et pourtant les mots peuvent
avoir différents sens et on ne se
comprend pas il y a des problèmes de
communication
je vous donne un exemple volontairement
très simple
un médecin
un mathématicien
il discute entre eux et puis j'arrive je
leur dis non non il y a un problème ça
va pas du tout il faut absolument
changer d'opération pour les calculs
on comprend qu'ils ne vont pas
comprendre la phrase de la même manière
ici le jargon est un problème
arrive un informaticien qui va voir les
médecins qui lui dit attention j'ai
chopé un virus
encore une fois la communication est
délicate
il faut souvent définir les termes ça
arrive plus souvent qu'on ne le pense
d'avoir des discussions entre experts et
puis on se rend compte une demi-heure
après qu'on parlait pas de la même chose
c'est le premier aspect le jargon
mais il y a un deuxième aspect
plus délicat plus sensible
les mots comportent avec eux une part de
contenu caché une part de subjectivité
je vous donne un exemple ici avec une
expérience
je vais vous demander si vous le
souhaitez de fermer les yeux et
d'imaginer les quelques phrases que je
vais vous donner on va imaginer la scène
ensemble moi je vais fermer les yeux
parce que ça m'aide vous pouvez le faire
aussi que vous soyez ici dans la salle
ou en train de nous regarder sur youtube
donc fermez les yeux et imaginez
l'autre jour j'étais chez mes parents et
puis moi je suis un peu gourmand alors
je vais dans la cuisine j'ouvre le frigo
et là en face de moi il y a un succulent
gâteau
je garde cette image en tête
j'ouvre les yeux c'est la fin de
l'expérience merci d'avoir participé
vous pouvez rouvrir les yeux si vous les
aviez fermé gardez cette image en tête
la cuisine le gâteau ici qui a réussi à
s'imaginer la scène lever la main s'il
vous plaît
une grande majorité de la salle
maintenant deuxième question qui parmi
ceux qui ont levé la main
ont déjà vu ce à quoi ressemble la
cuisine de chez mes parents
évidemment là j'ai plus personne
donc la question c'est
comment avez-vous fait
vous avez fait appel à une
représentation qui vous était
personnelle peut-être même qu'elle était
basée sur votre propre histoire
personnelle c'était peut-être la cuisine
de chez vos parents ou votre propre
cuisine
ce que je veux vous montrer avec cet
exemple c'est que même avec des mots du
quotidien cuisine frigo gâteau les
représentations personnelles internes ne
sont pas les mêmes
et c'est une des difficultés du langage
dont il faut prendre conscience
quand vous avez cette attention
particulière au langage vous commencez à
repérer les mots un peu partout ce sont
comme des icebergs
vous avez le contenu qui dépasse que
tout le monde comprend et dans la
discussion ordinaire on a l'air de se
comprendre oui c'est le petit bout de
l'iceberg mais le contenu caché lui
quand on y fait pas attention et qu'il
commence à y avoir une mésentente on va
commencer à s'y frotter ça va créer une
sensation un peu particulière une sorte
de distance une forme de dissonance
cognitive reprenez l'image avec le frigo
ah le gâteau
vous voyez le gâteau et vous me dites
comment pour vous ce gâteau
c'est un gâteau au chocolat
ou à la fraise pour moi c'était évident
c'est mon gâteau préféré c'est un gâteau
à l'ananas ou une tarte à l'abricot
le frigo
de quelle couleur est la porte
chez mes parents la porte du frigo
peut-être qu'elle est violette avec un
motif à pois
et évidemment la scène que vous avez
imaginée vous l'avez bien sûr imaginé en
pleine nuit c'était une petite fringale
nocturne
vous voyez quand on commence à préciser
le langage à définir plus en détail ce
Qi et caché dans les mots on peut faire
ressortir le contenu immergé de
l'iceberg
et on le retrouve dans presque tous les
mots du quotidien donc il faut
travailler cette attention
désormais quand on vous dira ah j'ai une
méthode performante un algorithme
efficace c'est la meilleure approche
vous pourrez prendre un pas de côté et
vous dire tiens
par rapport à quoi
ces mots-là sont subjectifs
alors je cherchais quelle était la
méthode
pour faire prendre conscience aux gens
de cette part de subjectivité dans le
langage
et je pense qu'une des solutions
possibles c'est d'intégrer les sciences
humaines dans les sciences fondamentales
dans la communication des chercheurs
mais aussi la communication de tout le
monde
vous voyez quand on fait des sciences on
a plutôt une approche manichéenne
binaire va réfléchir en vrai c'est faux
c'est noir c'est blanc c'est très absolu
quelqu'un qui au contraire pratique les
sciences humaines va être beaucoup plus
proche d'un contenu sensible va étudier
les effets des phrases comment les mots
vont nous affecter quelqu'un qui
pratique les arts la littérature va
s'intéresser aux effets de rythme ou
comment face à une audience avec
simplement un silence
on peut attraper l'attention de ces
spectateurs
donc la question est comment pour faire
de la pluridisciplinarité comment
va-t-on entraîner nos chercheurs à
prendre conscience du contenu des mots
de leurs effets
pour ça il y a un exercice possible
je pense que la vulgarisation
scientifique ou la médiation
scientifique est une pratique qui permet
aux chercheurs de travailler leur
rapport aux mots
c'est la discipline dans laquelle on ne
doit pas s'intéresser à comment est-ce
que j'aimais mon message du mieux
possible mais comment est-ce que le
message va être reçu
pour faire de la bonne médiation
scientifique il faut réussir à penser
comme si on était depuis la place de
l'autre
dans ses chaussures
et cette capacité à se décentrer
à penser différemment
c'est travailler son empathie son écoute
active comme pour le faire par exemple
un psychologue
on sent bien que dans la pratique cela
va forger une personne différente
et il se trouve que le CNRS
s'intéresse également à la médiation
scientifique vous le savez peut-être
chaque année le CNRS remet des médailles
à ses meilleurs chercheuses et
chercheurs ce sont les médailles d'or et
d'argent du CNRS
et bien en 2021 le CNRS a remis une
nouvelle médaille la médaille de la
médiation scientifique
cela signifie que pour cette institution
un chercheur ce n'est plus juste
quelqu'un qui produit une connaissance
de pointes nouvelle
fait de l'enseignement au sein de son
cercle mais c'est également quelqu'un
qui a travaillé sa communication pour
être capable de faire de la
pluridisciplinarité avoir un contenu
beaucoup plus transversal
c'est très important d'apprendre à
communiquer dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
face aux enjeux contemporains
nous allons avoir besoin de
scientifiques qui travaillent leur
communication
pour accompagner les changements de
l'intelligence artificielle il va nous
falloir aussi bien des ingénieurs des
informaticiens mais aussi des
sociologues des philosophes des
psychologues
pour faire face
au dérèglement climatique
nous avons compris maintenant que la
solution ne serait pas uniquement
technique mais qu'elle allait impliquer
des changements dans toute la société
donc un travail pluridisciplinaire
et pourtant
qui aujourd'hui
pensent encore que plus de plus trois
plus quatre degrés en 2100 c'est juste
un pull en moins
ici le mot degré
agit comme un iceberg on en a pas la
même représentation
certains voient un pull en moins alors
que pour d'autres plus trois plus quatre
plus cinq degrés c'est plutôt la guerre
de l'eau généralisée
la représentation est importante
pour résumer nous si on se fondamentales
avons besoin d'utiliser les sciences
humaines dans nos sciences
pour éviter que ces dernières ne
deviennent des sciences inhumaines
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]